hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich bin heute Babysitter
auf
etwas andere Art und Weise denn wir
spielen the baby in yellow und das ist
wohl irgendwie ein horospiel wir lassen
uns davon allerdings gar nicht
beeindrucken und tun einfach so als wäre
es ein ganz normales Babysitter Spiel hi
schöne Augen das Blinken da hinten so
[Musik]
war das jetzt
gut oder schlecht ich tun einfach mal so
als ob das gut war und wir tun doch
einfach mal weiter so als wär das hier
ein ganz normales Spiel wir können das
Baby nehmen
[Musik]
das war's mit dem Video der Kleine kommt
wieder mit rein wir schließen die Tür
und setzen den Idioten auch wieder hier
rein denn wir haben oben links da war
eigentlich meine face haben wir Aufgaben
die wir erfüllen müssen da steht als
allererstes dass wir mal die Flasche aus
dem Kühlschrank holen sollen deswegen
nehme ich jetzt einfach mal hier raus
Kühlschrank machen wir natürlich wieder
zu damit der ganze wurstkrams da drin
nicht abläuft und du steckst ja selber
ein schönes Bier
hat der gerade gefurzt der Baby zum
Wickeltisch bringen alles klar Bro bring
mal den kleinen Racker doch einfach
[Musik]
langsam wird's gruselig
das ist immer so
wenn man sonnenspiel spielt
okay
so wo haben wir eine Windel wir sind
keine hier unten drin kann man das
irgendwie aufmachen auch nicht wir haben
[Musik]
ich bin raus kann es denn sein
dass der gerade noch hier saß
und jetzt weg ist
will ich mich umdrehen
[Musik]
ich weiß jetzt komm wieder über viele in
den Kommentaren an 20 Milliarden
Spielstunde Teil 30 scheißegal ich hasse
sowas ich schwitze schon das ist
allerdings so halb so schlimm denn ich
habe ja
oh mein Körper zu hydrieren komplett
normale Wasserflasche
also das hier schon ganz normales Wasser
aber es schmeckt nicht so und das ist
das kranke an der ganzen Geschichte denn
man hat hier oben duftpods drauf ich für
meinen Fall z.B gerade heute Mango
Passionsfrucht es gibt noch ganz viele
andere es gibt auch tierische es gibt
Peach es gibt Cola es gibt Zitrone es
gibt Apfel es gibt ganz ganz viele
verschiedene Geschmäcker und wenn ihr
diesen Duft einfach ein bisschen nach
oben zieht könnt ihr einfach saugen
und ihr denkt ihr trinkt irgendwas mit
Mango Geschmack aber es hat keinen
Geschmack es ist ganz normal euer Wasser
ihr könnt das Sprudel reinmachen ihr
könnt da Naturell reinmachen das ist
komplett egal euer Gehirn denkt ihr
trinkt was mit Geschmack tut dir aber
nicht
das wird nur durch diesen luftpott
erzeugt weil die Luft zirkuliert und ihr
nehmt es auf in Rachen und euer Gehirn
denkt sie boah geil was mit Geschmack
ist aber nicht
ich weiß dass das über das Video so
schwer darstellbar ist aber es
funktioniert wirklich brutal
testet einfach mal also es ist wirklich
es ist verrückt wenn ihr Bock habt das
ganze mal Auschecken dann schaut in der
Infobox vorbei da findet ihr einen Link
zu er ab danke schön für Sponsoren des
heutigen Videos und wir
müssen jetzt bei diesem verdammten Baby
mal nachsehen was der Phase ist
wir tun so als wäre das ganz normale
Spiel nimm die
wow hi
alles gut es ist völlig normal dass ich
ein Baby teleportieren kann die klicken
jetzt einfach mal auf Baby wechseln und
sollen jetzt das Baby ins Bett bringen
ich denke mal die Betten sind oben dann
unten war kein weiterer mehr
sorry ich dachte ich kann mit links
liegt da rein aber der Raum ist gesperrt
das ist allerdings anscheinend der
Waschraum ist würde ich sagen schießen
wir den erstmal denn wir müssen ja ein
Schlafzimmer das müsst ihr dann hier
vorne sein so nicht du dich mal hier hin
was haben wir als nächstes Aufgabe
Geschichtenbuch finden und hinsetzt der
Typ kann sich teleportieren aber
brauchen verdammte Geschichte zum
Einschlafen die liegt auf jeden Fall ein
Buch namens der Prinz und die Katze und
dann setze ich mich jetzt mal hier hin
und lies dir was vor Minimum also Seite
Nummer 1
[Musik]
Deutschland Schnauze sie gingen durch
das goldene Tor schau die schönen Bäume
Prinz mochte egal Bäume zu fällen okay
oh wie süß
war Stadt auf Eltern warten auf dem Sofa
Fernsehen
ganz normales Babysitter Spiel und daher
taken wir uns sieht und chillen auf dem
Sofa
oh nein
oh nein wir schlafen
[Musik]
ich gehe da jetzt nicht hoch
ich habe die Tür zugemacht eigentlich
wie kann das sein
[Musik]
wie kann dieses kleine Kind das kommt
bis hier wie kann das überhaupt den
Türgriff betätigen na gut das kann sich
auch teleportieren wir müssen jetzt also
das Baby suchen
[Musik]
und es wieder ins Bett bringen
ist niemand
der Raum ist immer noch gesperrt
an der Decke klebt auch keiner
mich verarschen
[Applaus]
schlaf jetzt das richtige Plüschtier oh
mein Gott
hier im Baby Plüschtier
finde ich
was denn willst du eine Gummiente oder
was auch nicht
ich kotze ein Fick Hasen auch nicht alle
du willst keins von den die ich dir
gegeben habe
ich will mein Plüschtier
okay ich schau weiter raus
guck mal hier
auch nichts immer noch abgesperrt
[Musik]
entwickelt
auch keins
ich suche ein Plüschtier nicht einfach
eine Scheibe Toast nehmen
gute Nacht ich gebe ihm jetzt noch mal
jedes Kuscheltier den will er nicht
den habe ich
Arsch schließen alles klar
[Musik]
chillen auf dem Sofa Fernsehen okay das
ist die entspannteste Aufgabe die wir
mal haben ich mache auch mal hier die
Tür zu damit alles ist eine Richtigkeit
hat und wir chillen uns wieder hin und
schauen uns eine super tolle Serie an
denn wir schauen heute orange
[Musik]
oh nein nicht schon wieder einschlafen
nicht schon wieder einschlafen ich will
es gar nicht nein nein nein nein nein
nein ich will gar nicht ich will nicht
ich habe Angst was passiert
[Musik]
wir haben die erste Nacht überstanden